[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday September 16th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
Apple released its latest operating
system iOS 16 this week if you've got an
iPhone eventually you'll have to update
to the new system but some users may
prefer to wait to see if any kinks need
to be worked out so what can you expect
once you do update to the new OS and how
will it compare to other smartphones
joining us to discuss that is the Wall
Street journal's senior personal Tech
columnist Joanna Stern hey Joanna thanks
for coming back on the show Hey Zoe so
Joanna let's start with some things iOS
16 has that make it feel like an upgrade
what were your favorite new features of
iOS 16. personally I now cannot live
without some of the messaging features
one of those includes the ability to
edit a message so if somebody else is
running iOS 16 and let's say you have a
typo you can go and edit that message
for up to 15 minutes another feature in
messages that I really rely on now is
the ability to Mark as unread
basically text messaging has become the
new email we get so many messages and
this lets you just mark this as
important you can come back to it it's a
nice signal that hey this is something I
want to look at later I definitely
understand that I feel like there are so
many text messages coming in from so
many places these days that seems like a
nice to have feature though visually are
there big changes iPhone users will
notice in the updated operating system
so in the iPhone's 15-year history
there's never been a bigger design
change to the lock screen that's the
screen that we look at every day all day
and so now Apple lets you customize that
in millions of ways that's not an
exaggeration there are so many color
options for the fonts there are going to
be so many different widgets and of
course whatever wallpaper you'd like one
of my favorite things here too is that
Apple has these new pre-loaded
wallpapers one of them is a weather
background and it automatic
automatically changes based on the
conditions in your area another is
emojis so you can put in your favorite
emojis and it will do different patterns
on the background of the screen
obviously I have a poop emoji background
now all of these things and again I'm
not kidding you could spend hours if not
days customizing your lock screen now
and you can make different options I
don't suggest you do that but it is
really nice to have a customized lock
screen that's more yours or personalized
so Apple has released its new operating
system but while I've got you here I
want to ask about its new iPhones too
could you tell us a bit about the
different models that are coming out
this year and if they're worth the
upgrade look every year Apple releases a
slew of new iPhones right this year we
got the 14 the 14 plus and those are the
regulars as I call them more affordable
and then you have the pros the iPhone 14
pro and the 14 pro Max
usually I say that all of those are good
choices and some people will be better
with the lower end model some people be
better with the higher end models this
year my advice is a little bit different
in fact those 14 models really haven't
gotten that much better from the 13 just
in terms of cameras and battery life
it's not that big of a jump but the pros
now offer more features where that value
of going up two hundred dollars gets you
some more features that I think people
will really enjoy and those features
used to be really centered around the
camera right going from the regulars to
the pros you got a third camera the
telephoto camera now you get more than
that you get some real screen
enhancements one of those isn't always
on screen it means the screen always
shows your time and the date you don't
have to tap on it it just always shows
it
but then there's this other feature it's
kind of a screen technology turned
software trick it's called the dynamic
Island I'm not joking that's the real
name of the feature and in fact I went
and tested this on a real Island because
I kind of needed to poke fun at this
name but what this lets you do is
multitask and it is this island is at
the top of the iPhone 14 pro and 14 pro
Max screen and it is a little pill area
that's the shape of a pill which is what
was previously the notch area and so
Apple shrunk that down that's the area
that has the selfie camera it's the area
that has the face ID and so now this
area expands and retracts that's the
word dynamic and different software apps
or different apps can then live in the
island so you can jump between things
and it can display information like if
you're on a phone call it can display
the amount of time that's on the phone
call or you can tap on it to get to the
phone phone call screen if you're
listening to a podcast like this one you
can press and hold on the dynamic Island
to pause it maybe
sorry I could talk for a really long
time about the dynamic Island I'm very
Dynamic when I talk about it and maybe
very on an island right now or have you
left the island I left my Island I'm in
my office attic which is not dynamic
you know cameras and videos are often
the selling point for new phones are
there changes here that you liked Apple
over the last couple years has put in
new video tricks and this year the video
trick is action mode which means if
you're doing some action the phone
should stabilize the video and so to
test this I did a couple of things one I
went out to that island so I canoed
there and tried that you know the
footage wasn't that much more stable but
I definitely found myself running around
a lot to test this and you can see the
difference I wouldn't say that it's
major already the video on iPhones
starting with probably the 12 has been
really stable but if you get these
phones you're probably going to want to
run around and do some action
okay so how do all of these changes
compare to non-iphone or non-apple
software in both iOS 16 and the iPhone
14 models Apple plays catch up to
Android this happens every year some
features Android gets from IOS iOS gets
from Android specifically though in iOS
16 the ability to customize the lock
screen in this way feels very Android
Android has had a similar sort of
feature with their material design and
they introduced that about a year or two
ago also on the iPhone 14s again talking
about that lock screen on the 14 Pros
that always on display has been on
Android phones for years now
all right that's our senior personal
Tech columnist Joanna Stern thanks for
breaking this down for us Joanna anytime
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]